je trouve que l'influencé je pense que
c'est ce que pense moi aussi c'est un
milieu dégueulasse en fait le problème
c'est que instagram alors c'est quoi une
influence pour l'hôtel influence ce sont
des personnalités pas que de
télé-réalité d'ailleurs qui ont beaucoup
d'abonnés et qui font ce qu'on appelle
des placements de produits donc ils sont
sollicités par des marques de plus ou
moins bonne qualité pour tenter de
vendre des produits à un public souvent
très jeunes et très crédule et il ya
parfois des arnaques dans toutes les
agences d'ailleurs instagram a érigé
comme seul critère de réussite dans la
vie pour les jeunes la richesse donc
tous les jeunes aujourd'hui veulent être
riches veulent être blindé veulent être
des millionnaires or mathématiquement
c'est pas possible il peut pas y avoir
que des millionnaires je supprime donc
on se retrouve avec des jeunes qui sont
prêts à tout pour avoir l'air d'être
riche prêt à mentir près arnaquer leur
public près parfois à se prostituer
parce qu'il faut parler des coulisses
aussi de l' influence toutes les nanas
qui vont à dubaï pas tout mais une
partie qui partent à dubaï sur des
yachts avec des milliardaires pour
prendre une photo en string devant lieux
pour faire des like parce que c'est ça
c'est générer des laïcs aujourd'hui pour
exister et bas derrière doivent se
prostituent vainqueur stade il a fait la
paf un like non c'est un milieu malsain
c'est un milieu dégueulasse et c'est un
modèle qui est désastreux pour la
jeunesse et je pense qu'il faut que ça
change et on sa bomba sur le fond il a
raison et pour las alors donc vous vous
êtes plutôt team booba sur le fond je
suis timbo un bruit delphine alors moi
aussi sur le fond je sors timbo va bien
que magali nous a tous fait beaucoup de
peine parce qu'elle lui mais c'est un
sujet différent en fait le truc c'est
que il faut il faut pas jeter la pierre
à toutes les agences d'influenceurs
parce qu'en fait il y as agence
d'influenceurs et agences d'influenceurs
en 2019 j'ai bossé avec shauna events et
ça c'est très très vite fini parce que
effectivement c'est des produits qui
n'étaient pas de bonne qualité c'est un
peu compliqué au niveau de
l'organisation au niveau des paiements
c'est très très compliqué donc on
arrêtait d'ailleurs
en 2019 entente avec des produits qui me
correspondait pas du tout aujourd'hui
par exemple je suis dans une agence jeu
les produits voilà comme ça où les
produits me corresponde c'est de la
qualité et je fais que les produits que
j'ai testé par exemple ce que je veux
dire c'est que elle aurait dû tout
simplement dire depuis 2019 voilà on a
un peu des petits soucis on a fait des
erreurs mais aujourd'hui ça va mieux en
fait il faut juste il faut juste
accepter que voilà ils ont fait des
erreurs
alors mathieu toi je sais que là tu es
non ce qui me rend fou c'est quand
j'entends guillaume faire un espèce de
de melting pot tout il mélange tout des
filles à dubaï qui font la prostitution
des influences joué par exemple que
c'est à la base ce sont des gens qui
font de la publicité alors ok parfois
ils connaissent pas les produits mais
pardon c'est quoi c'est la publicité
moderne tu crois que sophie duez elle
nous fait du madrange non mais pardon tu
crois tu crois qu'ils étaient des
faiblesses mais norman l'hiver à 2 m
balmont à 4 urban blême rocade à ceux
qui croient que quake 3 des fenêtres
sans quoi art et fenêtres du maire les
gens c'est de voir des jeunes qui
désirent nous quintin mikell je crois
qu'il en soit d'après d'années qui
n'avait plus rien n'arrête avec aucun
talent ça veut dire quoi aucun talent
n'a aucun terrien mais c'est pas vrai ce
que tu dis ça je dis rien n'a rien dit
en bon aucun avis sur rien oui c'est de
finir mais l'habit la cena mais là c'est
pas pareil alors se nettoyer l'exil
les annonceurs qui n'ont aucun talent
qui sont tous tous les influenceurs il y
en a plein il va sur un état grave
regarde tous ces sommes énormes et la
vie deux cent mille trois cent mille
personnes qui se prennent tous pour des
stars alors que tout le monde en a deux
et qui passent leur vie à se pavaner en
faisant des coucous mes petits chats ça
va on en a rien à [ __ ] de leur vie
c'est insupportable voilà et ces gens là
n'ont aucun talent et je pense que ça
exaspère énormément de gens moi y
compris de voir ces gens rien faire et
violent il ya quelque chose à mon avis
et les gens qui tous les soirs regardent
la télévision et qui se disent y'a un
mec blond peroxydé qui tous l'espèrent
prend une tonne pour donner son avis en
politique alors qu'il a jamais rien fait
alors qu'il n'est pas légitime a dit
cette fois tu là c'est pareil excuse moi
je me lève le matin je travaille je
suis en quarantaine et que tu ne t'en
débuts en politique je suis désolé on ne
veut pas dire qu'ils ont un produit bon
mais ça n'a rien
il a pas de rejet c'est même moi je
passais sujet
de travail en fait le travail c'est ce
lever le matin c'est se donner du mal
séché pas être boulanger plombier très
beaux arts est à corn avocat
vrai métier et fluence heures et moi
j'ai fais parce que j'aime en a on a un
influenceur là raphaël oui je suis en
tentant ce qu'il dit dans les grands
mythes suis un peu d'accord avec toi
guillaume succès on a un peu pareil là
dessus maintenant quand tu proposes à
des mecs de 20 ans des gens de 20 ans de
l'argent bon alors vacances pour partir
bon allez peut-être serré des filles ou
série d mais non mais c'est vrai ouais
c'est ton genre comme ça d'accord on te
mets là t'as pas de diplôme ou alors tu
marches dans un truc que tu ne sais pas
mais tu ne connais pas qui attend depuis
17 ans c'est ce qu'on appelle l'argent
facile et xi allemand jouer derrière des
motifs donc évidemment je te dis pas la
question je vais te dire moi commencé
avec c'est fait je vais te dire
exactement
tu arrives à 20 ans propose un bon tu te
dis voilà j'étais serveurs moi ok je
suis serveurs on propose ça bon allez
vas-y j'y vais je vais voir et à 25 ans
tu as la vraie question entre 25 et 27
ans pas cette question que te dire et
c'est là que tu te poses la question
donc il ya plein de il n'y a pas de
mauvais côtés ya bien il a faim de côté
malsain mais mais il ya l'argent
qu'est-ce que je fais alors la question
s'est enflé raphaël affaire est ce que
c'est vrai feu il ya des produits qui
valent dix balles qui sont vendus 50
balles break mais mais alors évidemment
j'ai eu des produits mais ça a été sur
alex frei ne soyez pas dire non quand
même vrai je pars en fou pour te dire
non il ya des produits qui se vendent 10
balles apparemment que d'autres vents de
50 balles maintenant nous on n'est pas
entre guillemets
on fait moi en tout cas moi je parle
pour moi je me laisse pas le matin
devant tiens je vais voler la france je
tenir je vais prendre un truc sur allier
qui pèse et je vais le vent de 50 euros
alors qu'il m'a coûté 5 euros c'est pas
mon but d'accord on a une argile ou made
on a des agences le chevalier pourquoi
ces contrôles et en fait on travaille
main dans la main donc je remets pas
tout sur les agents c'est pas vrai
wysiwyg nous propose quelque chose tu
veux le faire où tu es toi tu sais même
pas ce que c'est en fait je sais pas
s'il y en a je sais ce que c'est ouais
mais c'est tout dépend les agents du
musée nous déplorons les agences avec le
bayer a fait ensemble
avant même de savoir évidemment les
agences et nous fait horreur c'est
arrivé contre avec des gens se rendent
compte que ces gens ne sont pas ne sont
pas si fiable que ce alors fabrice di
vizio téléphérique il a pris les patins
de booba alors pourquoi tu sais ce
qu'ils te dire mon moi il s'avère que je
suis entré dans la discussion parce que
par le jeu du cpf le cpf il a changé il
ya quelques années qu'on prend jamais
adopté le compte professionnel formation
j'avais alerté
en disant on était une équipe à avoir
alerté me reconnais en dessous de tout
ça est un nid arnaque quand
effectivement vous transformez les
points en argent que vous ne contrôlez
pas derrière il va ça y va abandonner
ces extracteurs carbone c'est pareil bon
le problème qui se pose c'est que moi ce
que j'ai vu danser dans ces deux des
balades avant tirs sur ton émission que
j'ai vu c'est quoi j'ai vu d'un côté
l'avocat de booba qui vient poser les
choses en termes juridiques expliquer
quels sont les problèmes qui se posent
j'ai vu de l'autre une jeune femme une
influence euse qui finalement
est patron d'une agence qui
effectivement tout à fait et qui vient
d'expliquer qu'elle a créé un métier
toutes pièces dont elle ignorait tout de
celui ci puisque forcément il n'existait
pas et qu' elle a peut-être fait des
erreurs mais c'est de bonne foi ah oui
mais s'il faisait mal elle consiste en
des pratiques commerciales trompeuses ou
dans les escroqueries s'appelle pas
désagréable à dire qu'est ce qu'elle va
dire voilà dit que s'il y avait eu des
erreurs et je suis allée qu'alain pays
non c'est quand
il faut a dit de ce à quoi il faut
redescendre sur terre quand même donné
je pouvais lire sur un plateau télé
excuse-moi gâche pas payer mes impôts
parce que je n'ai pas de fake je les
paye mais tu comprends c'est pas de ma
faute je suis désolé si à payer les
impôts de l'épais non c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe bien abandonnée elle
était responsable
du feu nouveau métier arrivé de dole
arrivé en plateau et venir expliquer que
potentiellement elle à arnaquer les gens
mais que c'est de la faute de booba qui
la harcèle et tout le monde à tous
récents tu mets le monde écoutez moi
c'est pas vrai excuses mot à dire a
failli tout le monde ici quasiment
beaucoup de gens même autour de cet art
on fait du personnes produit à un moment
donné
la mort donc on s'est repris et de
l'envoyer à benghazi a déjà fait mais
évidemment il y en a qui sont trompés
ils l'ont fait comme delphine comme
benjamin comme mathieu comme plein de
fonctionnement il ya eu des erreurs tout
le monde il ya des gens qui sont venus
voir et il appelait ça des erreurs ou
les gars mais vous avez l'assurance à
regarder attendez attendez pas aussi mon
patrimoine est tendue mais attendez il
ya deux minutes on m'explique qu'elle
n'est pas influencée 2 mai patronne
d'une agence maintenant à l'influent
second va choisir son camp
le problème ça mais je savais ce que
j'essaye de comprendre c'est que
finalement en shona et bugs mais vous
comme actionnaire
vous vous êtes là pour parler de tout
sauf de vote tout problème à vous de
votre métier vous êtes influenceurs
motion en devises et non lui c'est comme
ça
c'est la peau vous rentrez non je vais
venir moi j'avais adoré y arriver mais
j'ai bien joué monsieur
des bêtises je dois donner quand même
j'ai bien vu avec le 6
mais à 46 6 en un an mais monsieur
jacques a tranché quoi ça
où tu peux pas effectivement donné je le
bon d'accord on peut faire du buzz tant
qu'on veut mais il ya des gens qui se
lèvent le matin quand même franchi toute
la journée qui vont bosser mais j'ai des
chances qu'un saint germain je
terminerai que je termine il ya des gens
qui vont à la fac qui assume les
responsabilités quand moi je me plante
si moi je plante un client je peux pas
arriver et dire attends ouais mais tu
comprends c'est pas de ma faute je me
suis trompé c'est comme ça c'est parce
qu'elle a un amant
on pose une question de pourquoi on pose
la question de booba ce que je dis c'est
que booba a eu le mérite de soulever un
lièvre mais avant tout par
des gels berne estime quoi toi
excusez-moi m division moi je sui team
booba mais ce qui me dégoûte c'est
d'être dans votre équipe
qu'est ce que vous venez [ __ ] ici
répondre à ça c'était confus répondre à
cette manne est
la meilleure réponse qu'est ce que je
viens faire là c'est parce que je les
invite est effectivement vrai besoin
d'une expertise que vous n'avez pas été
foutu de données voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'était la mode des antilles vague
serait-il à éructer maintenant booba est
à la mode emo qui soutient plutôt vous
êtes à éructer dans une semaine
casquette à l'envers vous chantez
durable division
[Applaudissements]
comme d'habitude comme d'habitude vous
voulez on rigole quand même sur le fait
hier on rigolait sur des milliers de
morts et aujourd'hui on rigole sur des
milliers de victimes potentielles
d'escroquerie ce absolument besoin mais
c'est pour ça que j'ai écrit des
produits frelatés mais en quoi en bois
j'ai compris je savais bien défendre et
mieux lui qui nous avait planté les
milliers de victimes tous mes panneaux
au calme toi alors il alors d'accord
mais si je suis calmé par mam et le
juriste il vous répond que diffamation
ça existe et ça sur faudrait procède
vers des styles pascal met d'accord
avec simone et ma patience a aussi des
limites us a été contredit pas attaquer
quelqu'un d'avoir escroqué des gens ça
reste un délit moi j'ai pas dit que je
n'allais bones à croquer qui que ce soit
ses premiers points le deuxième point
c'est que ensuite on a le droit de
garder un tout petit peu de sérieux sur
et se dire que c'est à dire ça il ya un
vrai
danger était là parce que le patron de
la mission va vite et ne suis pas invité
tout seul la série là dedans
m
[Applaudissements]
wimille et était très bon sur koné et
ben arfa
brésil du coach bien si je ne la
laisserai de m la fabrique fabrice vidéo
quotidien sur un sujet il le connaît hip
hop je voudrais nous a fait sujet banon
mais l'origine du 2-0
ok
j'ai un doute parce que je vais pas été
je suis 44 électro cris quand je la vois
bien sûr vous mettez tout le monde dans
le même panier mais je vais les escrocs
et ce côté ajaccien de soi calme-toi
j'explique essentielle que le problème
la maison bombardée mathieu je conviens
cette crise ne pas te plaire mais ce que
soulève booba est un problème juridique
jusqu'à nouvel ordre le sol juristes
pour la entendu c'est l'avocat de booba
et toi et l'avocat effectivement 2 et de
toits de magali bertin et toi donc et
moi je à priori je m'excuse sur ce mode
commerciale trompeuse et son escroquerie
j'ai un tout petit peu plus des gîtes
84 ans je faisais alors je suis allée
vélo et tu en egypte 10 cas
pas la cause mais j'en sais rien de quoi
pourquoi tu le souhaites mais pourquoi
d'ailleurs j'ai même pas dire mon
passage au passage lui mais je n'ai
absolument pas dit mais absolument pas
dit que shauna events ou que magali
bertin
c'est l'épopée chéri j'aimerais bien il
ya quand même quelqu'un ici qui a qui
quand même dans le monde de l'influencé
aussi puisqu'il influence les gens à
dormir benjamin castaldi
[Applaudissements]
21h l'homme à la poitrine va faire ses
preuves a dit
que ce soit bien je suis plutôt team
influenceurs vas-y toi booba jeunesse
coach n'en ait mis plein les poches avec
des enfants du tout j'ai fait quatre
postes dans ma vie et je suis très
étonné parce que tes enfants font des
postes aussi mais moi alors je vous dire
c'est que nous jugeons les jours encore
si j'envisage l'on sait la bombe c'est à
mon avis que toi qui est nouveau fabrice
di vizio sais pas qui était spécialiste
de l'influencé fait spécialistes surtout
quand abou bakr j'aime beaucoup c'est un
rappeur le mec il vient faire des leçons
de morale sur l' influence au nom de
voix au nom de qui
d'accord il a raison pourquoi elle a
raison toi tu que statut si son
influence toutefois même dans ta boîte
tu cours tu fais de la communication
numérique ou non oui tu veux
il pensa le dossier du siècle
ainsi pour les entreprises on va
proposer à la fois par une collaboration
j'ai annulé le contrat de son entraîneur
tubos do la mort j'ai fait des censures
les influenceurs j'en ai fréquenté dans
ma vie privée j'ai aucun problème avec
ça c'est pour ça qu'il m'exaspère
d'autant plus et je ne gêne pas pour
leur dire je veux être moi ce qui
m'énerve avec les différences écrivait
de l'argent j'ai jamais gagné dans ma ci
contre a vendu des émissions
c'est que c'est le samoa clément qui lui
là bas
alors je te disais tous pareils ce qui
me gêne c'est que c'est le symbole de la
génération zéro efforts tu veux perdre
du poids à chetouane crème tu veux être
millionnaire investi dans des trous des
écriteaux monnaie bidon qui ont fait
c'est parce
qu'il veut gagner cinq emplois
permanents tous l'assurent mincom
invaincu mais c'est pas les syndicats
c'est ça m'aidait autour de toi dénudée
sur mym sauf que ça reste excédé pro
avec après malheureusement c'est il ya
des séquelles derrière tu veux passer
des vacances de rêve à bilbao on va sur
un yacht magnifique sauf qu on oublie de
dire qu'il faut accessoirement se
prostituer pour y aller
cher c'est dégueulasse d'un milieu des
deux cent quels sont les malversations
qui sont pointés il ya deux phénomènes
c'est le drop shipping c'est à dire que
des influenceurs voulait acheter sur des
sites des produits selon après on va
dire 10 euros et ils vont les revendre
même sans valeur ajoutée du tout à 30
euros on est là gros quand les gens ça
c'est une pratique inadmissible et
d'autre part des produits de mauvaise
qualité qui ont été livrées à des gens
notamment des produits esthétiques et
booba a réceptionné des plaintes à ce
niveau là qu'ils peuvent abîmer la peau
de mettre en danger la santé des gens et
là c'est inadmissible m quand tu dis pas
réceptionné dépeinte ça me fait rigoler
doubout bacchanales
excusez moi c'est ce qu'il a fait ayessa
nos paisibles obama ensuite de la drogue
shipping mais la vérité le problème
n'est jamais dit l'adresse de tous les
produits liés tous en étant honnête moi
j'ai rencontré plein d'influencés là on
est sur un plateau soyons maître
demeurer sur un plateau vous saviez que
ça se passait comme ça vous saviez très
bien qu'ils avaient des camps du coup
l'élu cher que ce qu'elles s'adaptent
est alors comment voulez que je le sache
puisque c'était tout début de
l'affluence mais affirmait je vais tout
changer les photos regarde le produite
il va tout de suite trouvé le prix moi
j'étais un
menteur mais moi je pense que en fait
vous essayez c'est le meilleur de ce que
vous essayez de faire des choses pas du
tout maîtrisée pas demain que moi je
suis content que les gens savent qui en
a fait de même au match de leur vie quoi
que non d'abord le drop shipping
effectivement ça je suis content parce
qu'ils ont exagéré maintenant si on part
du drop shipping pour des gens
comprennent bien ok ils vont acheter un
produit en chine qui bouge pas 2 euros
près selon m lors marque dessus chômage
m'appelle nabila et ils le vendent 10
donc la différence et 8 euros en plus
c'est la marque voilà si on est très
très très honnête avec sept principes
d'une marque nike qui fait ses
chaussures pour 10 balanchine hime nike
qui la vend bien finir donc si on est
très très mal la chose c'est dans cette
optique
tiens pardon les achète quelque chose et
ils ont raté la marche et un ascenseur
qu'ils aiment qu'ils ont vu à la télé
qu'ils aiment je dors tu as tu as plein
consommateurs de l'autre côté je peux
t'assurer que c'est vrai il ya maldonne
120 dérange c'est qu'on s'est vraiment
que les produits qu'ils achetaient c'est
parce que tu oublies dire quelque chose
dans l'affluence et qu'on disait mais
grâce à mon code promo de 30% vous allez
payer moins cher alors
mettez moi
je vois tu vas répond ya quelqu'un qui
dit pourquoi on repasse pas les vidéos
de castaldi qui étaient contre les
influenceurs avant que ses fils en face
jamais été contre des influenceurs
jamais c'est faux et c'est pas vrai je
trouve ça je trouve ça dommage de mettre
tout le monde dans le même panier de
faire des généralités le décile coûte
rien qu'ils sont tous des nuls des
comptes d'abrutis et en plus dans lequel
les influenceurs il me semble que c'est
plutôt ciblées contre ceux qui font de
la paix global mais on est conscient que
que sont les autres
de faire des jugements à l'emporte-pièce
mais voilà ils sont bons ils sont nuls
ils n'ont pas de talent je trouve ça nul
de rennes jus de raisin comme ça et
effectivement c'est un scénario et le
gabon évidemment c'est très mal c'est
évidemment interdit d'escroquer des gens
évidemment il ya des arnaques oui c'est
vrai mais on a besoin de faire ça de
faire un bordel de que ça monte dans les
tours 2-2 sociaux des
divisions il vole au secours on se
demande de croire de percer cause et moi
parce que franchement
de découvrir que dans l'affluence et
l'influencé des possibles la belle
affaire c'est pas du tout comme mamadou
bâ s'en prend à moi très basique le 13
mai j'ai regretté que pour moi c'est pas
automatique je veux bien voir ses
emplois soit la toute fin je
vous répondrais je vais défendre mon ami
des visions
des stalles désormais vous avez dit on
se fout de ça à des milliers de jeunes
notamment ya pas de dire miss et
palestiniens
il ya des milliers de gens qui ont prêté
leur confiance à des influences avouées
médéric et oui ou qui ont acheté des
produits d'effectuer
des vidéos répondait pas répondait on
s'en fout je voulais vous vivez mois
après les soieries s'il ya des millions
de personnes qui vous regarde oui ça
vous dirait m'arrivait de faire une
connerie abbassi te le confirme
cools et bêtises mais c'est bien que des
choses
je viens il comprend raison
effectivement il ya eu des choses qui
ont été mal fait mais comme tout le
monde le sait ici le monde de la science
ça a commencé en 2007 assure d'accord
savais même pas qu'ils ont d'accord dans
n'importe quel domaine n'importe lequel
au bout de dix ans vous verriez encore
des heures mais n'importe où enfin non
est-ce que évidemment aujourd'hui
regardez je vais le faire jégo qui
reprenait la route et à des gens
internationaux bled en semaine on met sa
fille s'il ya des gens que j'ai touché
je m'en excuse pas des jambes alors
merci mais on avoir produit pour moi
voir produits qui à 0,99 euro et qui
réduit à 30 euros ajoute fabrice di
vizio est ce que tu voulais répondre à
castaldi sur quoi en fait lem ça me fait
marrer votre plateau c'est que quand moi
je balance des trucs tout on est contre
moi non pas moi booba quand il est venu
il ya dix ans même chose que moi
[Applaudissements]
mais ce que je voulais dire c'est que
moi ce que je voudrais c'est que melle
agnès la mère on écoute moi n'est pas
question mais pas question de faire des
généralités sont pas sales bbc penser
que cette
faute pénale il faut les punir voilà ça
c'est incontestable il faut éviter
qu'elle se renouvelle donc qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui mais il
faut que les influenceurs et les
gouvernés et les gouvernants travailler
ensemble ici moi jouons n'ouvre je
copréside les états généraux
d'esthétique médicale qui s'ouvre
quelques jours là où cette question de
la peur d'être au coeur du projet
division où il fit abandonné je termine
il faut abandonner prendre acte que dans
les crises de civilisation qu'on
traverse ce qui va correspondre aux
consommateurs c'est l'éthique et il va
falloir à un moment donné et que chacun
fasse sa part du boulot 4 et on
réfléchisse ensemble et collectivement
verseaula avoir lancé deux sens dans le
cyber harcèlement c est ignoble il ya
des gens qui savent
alors gérard vié n'ont pas laissé par
les genres les normes et moi je aux
jambes et je sais de voir ce berceau de
moi non mais juste jeu qu'on vote n'a
fait que servir à moi moi des fonds les
influenceurs ça me paraît complètement
saugrenue et j'ai toujours défoncé la
téléralité j'ai toujours défoncé les
influenceurs surtout ceux qui sont issus
de la téléréalité ça montre que je
déteste que je trouve vide et tout ça
malgré tout malgré tout je comprends que
ce soit un métier nouveau que ce soit le
far west qui ait besoin de règles il ya
eu des voix lui et des sorties de route
et et n'importe quoi que il ya même des
pratiques mafieuses je suis d'accord
avec vous mais rien ne justifie un cyber
harcèlement dans sa chemise énoncé
quelques personnes au monde on est
d'accord 900 g personnes en étions là
encore les dérangeait pas dans
l'émission lire si j'étais lécher mon
dieu non j'étais allée j'étais la façon
j'ai rien dis oui mais je vais donc pas
me dire que cela veut dire qu'on
condamne quelque chose qui pourrait être
des pratiques dégueulasse d'influenceurs
mais vaut tout aussi joli film en
version
c'est-à-dire harcèlement jeu ça fait des
morts aussi coup parce que ça fait des
victimes mais aujourd'hui à la rentrée
scolaire mais me laisser ce qu'il a
utilisée booba nommé autres
l'idée quelque chose va se mettre
d'accord moi je veux pas que quelqu'un
moi j'veux pas que berda par exemple
elle se suicide pas casser malgré ses
cheveux pour les chances d'accord
ce sera un autre débat mais on fait un
métier parce qu'elle était en dépression
il
faut que ça se calme sur l on l'a dit et
qu'on nous a par exemple qui
commercialise de la baie ou de la weed
je sais pas si c'est éthique alors que
son fils unique et très très jeune en
quoi vous parlez des dix candidats car
voilà lui posera gagnant mais s'il vous
plaît delphine en tout cas d'avoir donné
un coup de pied dans la fourmilière
booba je trouve ça très très bien
puisque aujourd'hui le milieu de
l'influencé omniprésent sur les réseaux
sociaux donc c'est important que ce soit
cadré est par contre benjamin le fait
que tu t'en prennent tout le temps à
division c'est quand même incroyable
parce que je crois qu'il vient pas ici
n'est pas que c'est moi il n'est pas que
avocat spécialiste du coc vide assurant
couverts par le co lead en revanche une
autre étoile sujet donc tu connais tous
les sujets donc ne dites pas que vous
connaissez mieux l'influencent passe
mais parce que là même qu'avait choisi
anger on connaît pas un sujet en 24
heures
bien sûr l'émotion
et alors il est intelligent il a cultivé
son
travail c'est super c'est pas ça le
problème moi ce que je dis c'est que
s'il ya des victimes oui cette histoire
il faut que ça cesse
d'accord deuxièmement ça peut être
l'occasion de ce couple info minière de
réfléchir à ce milieu dans lequel
effectivement très précisément soulevé
que dont il s'est fait sur le tas c'est
tout ce qu'on veut et là maintenant il
faut peut-être prendre les choses en
main et venir effectivement mais
peut-être
parce qu'aujourd'hui la société et c'est
ça ce qui m'ennuie si sean hayes a fait
des erreurs s'il ya des malversations
dans sa société et moi j'ai travaillé
mais je serais le premier à le
reconnaître mais ce que je dis c'est que
pour le moment on est en train de la
traînée paris j'ai raté de gendarmes et
de foot savoie en faillite alors que
pour le moment il ya des inspections qui
sont faits et qu'on n'a encore rien
prouvé enfin mehdi baala
ça les zones et on est en flammes dire
que c'est une escroc nonnes et la vienne
n'a bientôt plus sur la base de cette
vaillance à rien et jean triboit drogue
est trop facile ça d'abord fait l'envié
c'est trop facile hier soir elle a
expliqué quand même a été là j'ai
regardé l'émission elle a expliqué sur
la dgcrf est venu qu'elle ait contacté
plusieurs personnes pour réguler qui
quand où ça on aurait attendu qu'on ne
voulait
donc elle est accusée donc elle est
accusée parce que il faut pas attendre
et à l'internet choses avancent et on a
mis
bien sûr c'est trop facile voulait il ya
2 minutes vous parliez oui voulez qu'on
fasse main dans la main tout ça nous
remet ça et vous méfier dans la musette
dgdi selon l'ifop avait une famille on
n'est pas copain vient du
cépage est exactement celle où d'autres
ont fait on à réguler les pratiques rien
d'autre excusez moi d'utiliser le débat
abandonné
les manières de booba pour donner c'est
de ça elles sont légales 22 sur mes
joueurs j'en sais rien ce sont les
gravats c'est marrant je me suis pas
intéressé
c'est important contre sas ensemble
c'est ce que vous avez dit oui oui vous
rappeler que ça ça va oui ok d'accord
vous venez ici pourtant vous tapez sur
nombre des hans et des idiots naples
assuré pète d'été toute la chaussée
comment voulez qu'on fasse un pas vers
vous sentir ses deux chiens alors laissé
le trio laisser ses rivales et par les
20 minutes ch par mail soit par les ok
merci donc comment on fait si nous on
veut venir vers vous mais toute la
journée on se sent insulté comment on
fait pour vous ouvrir les portes et se
dire qu'on va faire quelque chose
ensemble parfaitement à ce qui passait
pour comme ça que vous tapez 2 jusqu'ici
c'est ce que nous avons envie de venir
voir chanter j'étais ensuite tenait tout
le fait de finir je voudrais pas c'est
que vous moi
excusez moi je veux dire ça vous
intéresse pas que j'aurais pu vous êtes
la victoire à nantes hier soir hier soir
magali berne a été la victime de booba
nouvelles victimes mais si vous êtes une
victime permanente pour l'instant les
vraies victimes ce sont celles vous m
je vais vous ramener
m e division moi j'ai une question très
calme à vous posez vous parler les
victimes les victimes les victimes
est-ce que vous avez pas tout simplement
par opportunisme senti le bon filon
magique vous vous dites vous mais il ya
des milliers de victimes
figurez-vous que après que booba mais
introduit dans la bouche de contact et
je division b bdc bout malgré dix ans
mais ce qui est des petits pains pas
[Applaudissements]
je
vous êtes bien que choqués ont fait à la
ronde je ne cèderai pas vraiment déçu je
voudrais surtout pas vous manquer de
respect cette image fait bien l'univers
qui nous séparent quand même
partir de là j'ai à partir de vous
obliger à faire quelque chose que je
n'aime pas vrai c'est comme à abandonner
de vous ramener
le mépris parce que vous êtes méprisable
dans votre propos quand même mais je le
connais pas et je ne vous agresse mais
je suis déçu du tout je suis ok on va
tirer dessus alors se réfère gilles
verdez c'est marrant cette proportion
que vous avez toujours à ramener les
choses à l'argent vous avez un problème
avec ça manifestement parce que moi je
vais vous dire la différence entre vous
et moi c'est que si je connais l'état du
droit fait craquer sur les influences je
me permettrai jamais sur l'âge de venir
prendre en charge des victimes de ça
parce que justement je ne suis pas
suffisamment spécialisés et donc à
chaque fois que les victimes se sont
présentées avec des histoires entre
shauna les boss d'ailleurs tiens
absolument à brac adresse pour y
chercher à savoir si c'était vrai je les
ai renvoyé dans l'avocat de booba merci